getting started on youtube really is as
easy as picking up the camera and
pressing record but
sustaining on youtube is usually the
hardest part for
creators and that's why i'm excited
about today's interview because tony
from the think media team interviews
two youtubers well business owners who
are sustainably running youtube channels
that have each reached over 4 million
views
i'm excited to dive into this week's
episode
welcome to the think marketing podcast
the number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
i'm heather torres and i'm sean cannell
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening
welcome this show is dedicated to
helping you learn how to get your
content noticed and the latest money
making strategies working right now
online so whether you want to grow your
youtube channel
or you want to maximize video across all
of social media this podcast is for you
well if you are anything like me you
love a great success story and today's
episode has not one but
two amazing success stories the first
one
comes from nicole of kids ot help nicole
is a parenting coach
a speaker and a kids occupational
therapist
she has built a thriving community of
moms of over
85 000 subscribers and over 4
million views she actually had one of
her videos go viral
which has allowed her to reach so many
moms in those early stages of motherhood
and the second is ben from keto camp ben
is a best-selling author who has built
an online empire
dedicated to helping people live a
healthier lifestyle he started youtube
just over a year ago and he just
surpassed a hundred thousand subscribers
with over four million views now all the
numbers all the accolades sound great
but
what's it really like what's the
struggle like what was it like getting
started and how do you sustain this
while also growing a business i think
these are critical questions
to be asking because i know as a
business owner it can be
so difficult to not just get started but
to keep
going so let's dive into today's episode
where tony from the think team
interviews both nicole and ben and we
get into all the juicy details of how
they did it
coming up i want to hear what maybe your
guys's experiences was when you were
first starting your channel
and maybe some of maybe the challenges
that went along with that and
how you were able to overcome that and
i'd love to start with ben first how did
you get
how did you start what was that like for
you yeah when i launched my channel i
made a commitment to put out a new video
every monday and friday and i got really
clear on my
why why do i want to put out these
videos why do i have a channel and i
believe once you get clear on your why
the how becomes much easier so for me it
was no
it was a very slow start right from this
from the get-go right
i was putting out a video monday and
friday monday and friday and i
it didn't grow as fast as i would like
but i was committed to the message and i
really thought
i believe that it was just the universe
way of testing me
so i was that that that stream that beat
the rock because
at the end of the day it's consistency
that wins so monday friday monday friday
sharing with everybody
incorporating some of the things you're
learning
the the framework and all of a sudden i
had one video
so let me just rewind for a second it i
launched my channel
17 months ago i'm about to hit 100k but
the four
the first five months so five months in
or so i had 342 subscribers
uh one of my videos started to
go viral right but it but i believe the
fact
that that happened was because i was so
consistent and i was
it was it was a test for me right so
there were times where i wanted to give
up
there were times where i was frustrated
because the growth wasn't there
but i committed to releasing a video
every monday and every friday because i
was clear on my why so i would
i would want you and i challenge you to
get clear on your why
why do you have your channel why do you
want to launch a channel why do you want
to
get this information out there who is it
going to help and put that in front of
you on a consistent basis
and then when when you don't get the
growth as fast as you want
that's going to help you persevere and
it's just the universe's way of testing
you so fast forward to today
94 000 subscribers in about 17 months
and i've
even increased it and learned along the
way but yeah that's my word of
encouragement for you get strong
on your why and the how becomes easier
well i have to like
i have to just applaud ben there because
that's amazing the results he got in 17
months
and so much of what i want to say is
going to piggyback off of that
so ben knew his why right away and he
committed to taking consistent action
and
i started very differently i was not
consistent
i wanted to tiptoe and i was in my head
a lot so i was constantly like oh
is this what i want to do i'm worried
about what people are gonna think
so just stuck in my head and stuck in my
fears and that kept me
from committing and being consistent for
probably a good
year and a half or so but when i did
make the decision to be
committed and it started with just one
video a week i have
a four-year-old son now but at the time
he was pretty young i was like
all right let's do this one video a week
things did shift and at that same time i
was implementing
a lot of these pieces of the framework
that you guys are using and
it took a little while for that to fall
into the algorithm and for youtube to
pick it up
but like ben i had a video that took off
and went viral
and it was at that point where i was
like okay i see the potential of this
and what i really want to like share
with you guys as well as ben singh i
want to challenge you with this is
i think about the time i've sort of
wasted dilly dallying
i'm like so now it's been four years
that i've been on youtube and
two of those years i was in my head and
so if i started from the beginning and i
said what's my vision
what's my vision and who do i need to be
to accomplish
what's in my vision so how does that
person show up well that person doesn't
dilly dally
that person says i'm going to do one
video a week she does one video a week
that person gets scared she moves
through the tools that she has
to help her show up whether that's
meditation
whether that's journaling whatever it
may be clear it
let it go and something else i want to
add is that a lot of times when we are
in our head and we're thinking about
what other people are going to think
about
us we're forgetting that there are other
viewers out there
who are waiting for the video that we're
going to put out um
i can look back now and i can say oh my
goodness like the messages and the
emails i receive
thanking me for doing the work and
showing up and putting out this content
has truly made a difference in other
people's lives and i promise you the
same will be true
for you so it's getting out of your own
way
being clear on that vision and then
saying
how does that person who has all of
these things
in my vision show up and be consistent
and i promise you growth will happen
that's amazing and what's so cool is i
feel like
everybody has a journey on youtube right
and it's i think it's important for you
know people to realize like you're gonna
stop like you're gonna
you're not there's some weeks you're not
gonna make the once a week like i happen
to it happens to me it happens a lot of
us
but there's a matter of creating that
consistent vision of why and go no no
i'm going to commit
to keep keep going for that goal keep
building this channel
and i'm i'm really interested to know
for you guys when did you start seeing
you know i kind of mentioned last night
in the interview if you guys were
watching the chat
i i mentioned that sometimes i feel like
when you're starting a youtube channel
it's kind of like
when the way a train travels you're
putting all this fuel in
and you're just like putting fuel in and
you just feel like do i have any more
fuel to put into this furnace to burn
and like keep this thing moving
but then you start getting a little bit
of traction and it's almost like extra
like
pieces of coal start falling into the
falling to the furnace you're like wait
i'm not putting that in it's almost like
it's re-energizing me now and giving me
more
motivation and more steam and so i want
to hear from nicole first
when was the first moment you noticed
maybe some of those those lumps of coal
coming back into your engine
from external sources not just from your
in your inside
um wow and it's something that continues
to happen
so even now when when i get in my head
about
what my next big goal is and i'm
thinking oh it's not happening as
quickly the universe will give me those
pieces of coal as tony will say
um in the beginning i would say it was
a lot of other i'm a pediatric
occupational therapist so
i'm in the health care field and it was
a lot of other
health care professionals that were
saying this is so helpful thank you i'm
teaching these concepts that you're
talking about
um in my private practice or where i
work and it's helping a lot of families
so it started with just like the
community building and the saying like
i'm here with you i see what you're
doing and i really appreciate it but
then
bigger things started taking place um
one
really big example was i had the
vice chair of occupational therapy
so we're run and we're licensed we're
like a licensed
association occupational therapy and ots
are all over the world
but the vice chair of china reached out
to me found one of my videos on youtube
and said hey look
um pediatrics is not a well-known
or well you know worked setting here in
china because of the laws that were in
place with how many children
people could have but since that had
been lifted they found there's really a
need for ots to learn the pediatric
setting
can i please use your videos on youtube
to help
retrain occupational therapists in china
i was like uh what say so we've been
working together and
and it's just such a beautiful thing
it's impact impact impact
and that became so clear in my heart
like this is why i'm here i can reach so
many people throughout the world and i
can have
my actions have ripple effects that i
can't even comprehend in this moment of
time
so that's that's one example and things
continue to come
and it's you trust you learn to trust
the process
it doesn't always happen on our timeline
but you trust that what you're doing
does have an impact and amazing
opportunities
lie in the future for you if you
continue on your path
that's amazing i'm really excited to
hear about ben as well when did you
first notice
that coal coming back into the furnace
and you being re-inspired by what was
actually happening
yeah that was awesome sharon nicole
thank you for that first of all
uh yeah for me it reminds me actually of
when i was going through
my weight loss transformation but i was
obese for most of my life i don't know
if you know that but
i weighed 250 pounds uh back in 2008 and
i went through this transformation
and the reason it reminds me of that is
because when i started to embark on this
health
transformation similar to embarking on
this youtube
goal here uh it kind of sucked you know
i'm not gonna lie i
uh when i would go to parties i would
have to eat healthy and my friends would
make fun of me i would work out i would
be sore so relate that to youtube
put out videos one view five you seven
views it kind of sucked you know people
would say things about you who
you know who does ben think he is and it
kind of sucked but here is my formula
for success and then i'll answer tony's
question
the formula for me is suck suck suck
cess okay i leaned into the suck and i
just kept pushing forward
and i essentially broke the universe is
what i call it so
for me it was similar to what nicole
shared about the emails she's been
getting
i i'm somebody who's very goal oriented
so i write down i haven't missed a day
in almost four years and i got this from
grant cardone who lives right
down the street from me here i haven't
missed a day of writing down my goals
every single night
and every single morning for almost four
years and one of those goals is
waking up every day to emails all across
the world from people i have impacted
with the work
that i have done and it wasn't until my
youtube channel started to really take
off that i started to get those emails
now they're coming in in abundance
there's people who have gone through
transformations there's people who have
been
suicidal letting me know that my videos
help them get healthy get off their
insulin get off their meds and
essentially reverse serious diseases
that they thought could not be reversed
so that's
for me was that coal that tony talked
about that just lights me up and gives
me stamina and gives me purpose
and i had to embrace the suck before i
got there but now
that fuel it's lit up and that's a fire
that will not go out for a
very long time that's amazing and
what i love about you guys said is that
i feel like people
maybe come into the youtube i don't know
i don't know if you guys are this way
you let me know but
i feel like sometimes people come into
youtube and thinking they want views
like thinking they want subscribers
thinking they want and i get where that
comes from
but how did you combat that where maybe
you came in going like oh i need more
views or did you did that ever crossed
your mind or was it always like no
no matter how many people watch i'm okay
with it or how did you battle that
mindset ben
yeah well learning from from the
framework that everybody's learning here
is speaking to one person you know
looking at
if i'm able to impact the life of one
person uh
that's a blessing in itself so focusing
on that one person how how can i deliver
this message and for me
here's here's a valuable share that
really helped me transform my speaking
ability
on camera was getting out of my own mind
and how i look how i sound do i look
cool
taking my attention off myself and
putting it on the person in front of me
whether it's one person or a hundred
people
so i started to focus on one person and
i would make up a name for this person
and i would talk to that person and all
of a sudden
it started to grow because i showed up
more authentic and i see that with
nicole by the way
this is my first time meeting nicole
she's so authentic and i imagine she's
doing something similar she's not really
focusing on
uh how can i get this into so many
people's hands but she's focused on that
one person
i am as well how can i make a big
difference in their life so it's just
focusing on that one person taking your
attention off yourself
and putting it on that person helped me
big time and how about you nicole what
was what is that like for you
ben's killing it over here i'm like he's
two steps ahead of me but um
exactly well and i so what i want to add
on what ben
said is which was great about the haters
because so much of it was
me being in my head about the haters
from the start is that
haters are confused fans a lot of times
when we say things we're gonna trigger
people sometimes for better for worse
and their emotional response
may may come out in a comment
um some people are emotionally
intelligent others are not
but you have to be okay with that
because as ben said it's the power
of one i mean the life-changing emails
that he's been receiving from people
um the transformation that can happen
and i think that's that's why it's just
so important to be connected to that why
in that vision because you're
you're speaking to one person one person
can make such a huge difference
um for me i'm i'm very much into
intentional parenting or conscious
parenting and i speak about the power of
one
if i can if my message can resonate with
one person
and they feel like yes i want to take on
this journey to
consciously parent my child their child
the trajectory of their child's life is
forever changed and then
that parent's grandchild right and we're
shifting generations
from the power of one person so
everybody has the ability
to deeply impact someone and so don't
let
the haters just distract you or detract
you
because a lot of times they'll come back
years later i mean i'm sure sean and
heather at the point now where people
who may have said not nice things in the
beginning are like you know what
i actually got a lot of value out of
that thank you you know people go
through their process
um so showing compassion and empathy for
that and saying like but look i got a
vision i got a mission and i'm staying
on track
so yeah just wanted to add that that's
amazing
and for you guys being a part of our
community and like our you know coaching
program and video ranking academy
what has it been like being in that
community like what is that has that how
has that impacted your channel
when you guys came into contact with it
and not only just the head knowledge
because i always like to think
that youtube is almost it's like 80
behavior and like consistency and like
20
head knowledge and knowing the right
things to do and all that's important
but
how did the community aspect come into
play um for you nicole
with being a part of what we're doing
here oh it's amazing um
you just so much support and
again i'll go back to just like the
inner game and having someone
people multiple people who understand
your journey
um it's like all of a sudden you go from
feeling like an outsider because maybe
your mom your dad your best friends uh
the people that you're nine to five
don't understand
this path um but you have a community of
people who support you and who are
walking
taking the same steps and you feel less
alone and i think that's
so important when you're doing something
that
is scary when you're doing something
that's new when you're building
the muscle to continue and and it's like
our confidence is compounded courage
right so we've got
to be courageous time and time and time
again until we build the muscle to have
the confidence and a community is so
important for that i'm all about
community and so
it's been a huge part of learning
evolving
growing and success so it's amazing
that's awesome ben how about for you
what did what was it like being a part
of the community how has that helped
fuel what you're doing
yeah well i love to share about it's a
muscle that you develop i agree with
that nicole
yeah you know it's it's one of the best
things you can do because
you take decades essentially trying to
figure out on your own you turn decades
into days like tony robbins says so if
you could
get access to a community that feels
like family that could guide you
it's like oxygen to your soul it gives
you stamina it gives you that fire
so you might have heard that your vibe
attracts your tribe
well you're going to attract an amazing
tribe here in this community is
incredible
something that i was writing down as
nicole was talking about was speaking
was that if you want to go fast
yeah go alone you'll go fast but if you
want to go far and make an impact you go
together and this community is how you
go together
and it's a shortcut to success and for
me i would do it all over again several
times over because it's made a massive
difference
in my growth and essentially helping
more people on planet earth that's what
it's about
getting this information that we know we
believe in can change lives and you
could do that with community so it feels
like family
tony heather sean everybody that i'm
meeting in this community and now nicole
it feels like family they're so
encouraging and that is really oxygen to
my soul
i think that's such a mantra of when
you're talking about want to go far you
go together
i feel community is something that can
be very like from someone like me who's
very tactical and i can think about the
tactics
and all that those things it can be
something that someone could overlook
and be like oh no i
just need to know how the algorithm
works i just know i need to know
how to title my videos i just need to
know those things
and i just have seen time and time again
that actually having a community
and having those things are going to
fire your soul up and seeing the success
of other people and motivating you and
reminding you like
this is possible that i can do this
is vital to having actual longevity
and i just think it's so brilliant that
what you guys have done
is not even just you know you're not
even just for yourself now you're
actually inspiring others to do the same
um which is pretty amazing but i want to
kind of jump into some actual
videos maybe you guys is like your big
like videos you're super proud of and so
i want you guys to think that i think
that through for a second what videos
you're like hey i'm super proud of it i
can pull up and kind of show here
what that we're making you know either
some of your massive success videos
um but i would love to start with ben do
you have one that you've you've had a
massive success on you're really proud
of
that you'd like to share yeah yeah it's
15 uh i fear the title but 15 steps all
keto beginner beginners must follow i
just released it last december so it has
like 120
000 views i believe but that one i i put
a lot of uh
like you talk about the frameworks you
know research before you record that one
i did a lot of research beforehand and
i'm really proud of that of that video
amazing look at this 144 000 views
january 1st 2020
amazing it's amazing when like the
research and everything takes place and
it almost like the star is a line
and it's but you know what's funny about
it though is that we see successes like
this
or you see like your big videos i i
don't know if you guys can relate
but i feel like not every video is gonna
have that feeling for you though
like there's gonna be videos and you
guys probably can relate to that where
it's
okay the stars didn't align i thought
they would align and they didn't
and what what do you guys do like like
for this video for example ben like
in between this video was there a lot of
successes just as successful as this one
no there wasn't i mean i mean i mean got
to define the word success there i think
all the videos were successful
as long as i researched them and i put
it out there but they weren't as
impactful as this one no
there's uh you know you just it's the
consistency that nicole and i are
talking about you know
you become consistent all of a sudden
you're gonna have those videos that take
off
those videos that don't take off but if
you follow the framework it's gonna
they're all gonna be successful so
that's my thought on that
that's amazing now nicole what maybe you
can walk us through a story of
like one of the videos you're like super
proud of how did it come into being how
did you
how did the video get made what happened
with it so my
my viral video is uh tummy time for
newborns
and the timing is actually really funny
because i think that was the first video
that i
created right after um i had
joined the coaching the youtube coaching
and implemented the framework
um and interestingly enough youtube
again as i mentioned before
it's not something that took off right
away it actually took a few months for
it to fall into the algorithm
and it it did it just took off
that's how most of my viewers find me
and we hit 1 million views in
october and now we're almost at 2
million views like some seven months
later so it's crazy
um and as ben said not
obviously not every video is going to
perform like that
but when you have a video that does well
that's where that can be your anchor
point that's where people can find you
that video
brings in 3 000 new opt-ins on my email
list
a month so it only takes one video
you know it only takes one video and you
keep going
and you never know it may be months a
year later
the video that you did a year ago falls
into the algorithm and it starts ranking
so
as ben said consistency keep your eye on
your vision
and magic happens it's amazing i think
it's
very much you've developed a consistency
of posting develop a consistency and
it's almost like you just keep not
try to do i feel like the big fight with
youtube is fighting discouragement
and fighting like that's the fight you
know maybe we think like oh that
competition is you know all these other
people it's really
it's fighting the fight of being just
discouraged about maybe where you think
you should be
or where you you know oh i should be
this far i should have i should i should
be like ben right 17 months i mean this
guy's like got a full titan company but
i i would love to hear uh what kind of
results you're seeing now been with you
in your business and
and how you're able to monetize that
those things because people are
wondering about that they go how do i
turn
this youtube in an actual business how
are you doing that right now
yeah i just love what you just shared
tony because it's really not about
competing against me
or nicole or really anybody else i have
shirts that i wear all the time that
says beat yesterday it's about beating
who you were yesterday and just that's
who your competition is that's the only
competition is who you were yesterday
and if you could just beat yesterday
you're a success in my eyes and yeah
your question is what has it done for me
in terms of my business
it has been the biggest source for those
finding my work
it's youtube number one for me uh
podcast a second youtube's number one so
i've been able to
uh uh obtained over 30
000 emails just from youtube so like
nicole was sharing which is amazing with
that video
i got i've been able to get 30 000
people over 30 000 people
opt-in to my emails from just youtube
okay and i haven't i didn't spend a cent
on any of those emails i haven't even
run any youtube ads
yet so that's those people who are
actually saying i want more of your
information i want you to send me emails
so what has that done
for me financially it's been a game
changer
here's something that i hope inspires
you i live in beautiful miami beach
florida i live in this nice beautiful
building with my girlfriend
youtube covers my my rent and more
okay so just from you turning ads on
from youtube not from
business not from what it does to my
business but just turning on ads
pays for my rent now you could transfer
all those emails that i now use for
affiliates and into my programs and it's
much much more than that but just by
turning on ads
it pays for my rent so it's been a game
changer for my brand
for my business for more speaking gigs
for more podcast
opportunities and my podcast by the way
the ketocam podcast it's a top 15
podcast
in the united states and the reason it
is is because i had so many emails that
i collected from youtube
that i could share the podcast with so
it's just now trickling
into all my other social medias but for
me all roads
lead to youtube that's incredible
that's amazing and what i would love to
do is like nicole as well how
how is youtube not only with youtube ads
as well like ben mentioned that's like
incredible
for you how are you monetizing how are
you seeing your business grow
as a result of putting consistent videos
on youtube yeah that's incredible ben
congratulations um for me again
as ben was saying it's like we have this
funnel that we've created right like
this is where people discover us
i have thousands of people coming in on
my email list
a month and then from there they're
getting introduced to various offers
that i have so i have
a whole suite of courses for brand new
mamas um
so tummy time course i have um how to
transition from breast milk or formula
to solid foods
um and then i just recently did a
breastfeeding course for moms
i now offer private coaching so
especially for my entrepreneur mamas
it's like how do we balance all of this
how do we show up as intentional parents
but also build the legacy that we came
here to build that we have the vision to
build
so it's just bringing so many people
into my world and again
for me it's like these opportunities
that come out of the realm
of potentiality like i was just emailed
by a book publisher that's like we're
interested in doing a series with you
would you like to write a proposal and
so these are all things that weren't
even
on my radar but they allow me to
expand my business and my vision and
have various
streams of income so that way you know
i'm not just relying on any one thing
which has been
amazing for me and as ben said it's like
i just recently launched a podcast so
now i can take these email subscribers
and redirect them to
the podcast or my private facebook group
that i have so
it's just this endless opportunity when
you are able to be discovered on youtube
it's it's it's amazing that's incredible
so and i imagine like both of you guys
obviously are
monetizing your channels not like
complete like oh i bet you youtube's
probably not
the only way and maybe not even the
biggest piece of the chunk of how you're
able to monetize on youtube without
being correct with you guys
correct yeah okay correct amazing and so
ben are you doing courses as well
online courses yeah yeah so i have uh
what's called my keto camp academy so
it's a membership uh it's 39 bucks a
month i have almost 300 members in there
mostly from youtube when i and i asked
him you know where did you discover me
and it's
90 plus from youtube so that's just one
avenue and then i do one-on-one coaching
like nicole says
and uh affiliate marketing a lot of the
things that you're learning in the
framework
i do so it's multiple streams of inc
income
equaling multiple streams of impact you
know the more income you make the more
of an impact you can make in this world
and
i'm a believer that we live in an
abundant world and
one of my favorite quotes is from
abundance he took abundance and what
remained
was abundance so everybody's do their
fair share of abundance it is our
birthright and right now
more than ever with what's happening in
the world online it's where it's at
youtube is
well google is the number one search
platform in the world
google owns youtube but youtube is
number two so it's just gonna explain
expand even more especially how as more
people enter the
online world youtube is where it's at
that's amazing and one of the questions
i asked last night in my interview that
i'm really excited to see your guys's
take on this
is if you were to start youtube
all over again if you were to like go
back to day zero with all the knowledge
and experience you have now
what are the two maybe two or three
things that you would focus on
first so where would you apply your
energy your spare time
i mean maybe working full-time obviously
being a parent like
where would you invest your limited time
where would you invest
invest in that first and i'll start with
let's start with nicole on this one
um for me it would definitely be
the inner work first and getting very
clear on my vision
um because when i first started i don't
think i had
the tools to help me be in alignment and
and be consistent so i've learned now
how important that is
you know again if you need a mentor or a
coach or whatever it is here you have
this community of people
with all these brilliant stories of
their lives and what they're doing to
like push through
these tough times and when i first
started youtube i didn't have that so
you could see the power of community so
in hindsight i would have started with
this
it took me a year and a half to find
shawn and heather and everybody so it is
what it is
um but then also i think that ben
brought up a great point is just
that clarity and that commitment if i
would have set okay what am i really
committing what am i doing on here
what's what's the game plan and
how am i going to get from a to z things
could have happened faster so
inner work community and then just again
that clarity on why
and and the strategy of how
that's amazing and you know what's funny
about that that about all those things
you said and even like last night when
i'm
picking up here is no one said oh like i
would have gotten a better camera
or like oh i would have um learned what
frame rate was
or uh i would i would have learned you
know uh
this like no one's saying that because
those are just like
ingredients and ingredients in the
recipe it's not the main part of the
recipe
and ben i'm really interested to hear
your answer on this where would you
focus
your first two or three areas if you
were starting all over with everything
you know now
yeah better equipment now i'm just
kidding
i mean what amber said excuse me not
amber what nicole just said
uh inner work inner sizing you know
getting clear
on your why really get clear on it write
it out in front of you you talked about
the clarity i forget we said that you
have a clarity
a report fill that out and get clear and
keep it in front of you i think it's
important to keep it in front of you put
it on your wall put it as your wallpaper
so get clear first and then yes
investing
in in these courses investing in
whatever sean
and and heather has for you because it's
a shortcut to success
it's an investment in your brand in your
message
and in your company whatever you want to
develop in this world so get clear
on your why keep that why in front of
you and then invest
in proven methods right i'm a big
believer that we look
that we should seek counsel not seek
opinions okay that's the difference
between
asking your friends what they think
about your youtube channel versus asking
heather or tony or somebody
who actually knows this stuff so seek
counsel and this is the best opportunity
to do so
and what i said earlier it takes those
decades of research and frustration
and it turns those decades into days so
clarity and then do whatever it takes to
get access to this information to learn
how to do it
we have a question in the chat that i
saw pop up which i'm really interested
is is giving an example of your why
and so i'd be really interested to know
what some of your what your guys's whys
are why did you what
what was your motivational that kept you
through that thing that you may be kept
in front of you ben
or nicole the things inside of you that
was really buzzing around that kept you
pushing through
let's start with nicole what was that
thing for you well it's evolved over the
years and i think that it's okay for
that to happen i think that is a
representation
of your growth as a person so when i
first started
and i was really clear on what i was
doing and why i was doing it
it was because as an occupational
therapist i was working
in an outpatient setting and i was
working with kids who were severely
physically disabled
and it's it's
beautiful work but it's hard sometimes
on
the therapist because with that
particular
population you don't always see um
them progressing it's almost like a
maintenance of where they
are and there's this yearning to help
people go
further and so i really wanted to take
my knowledge and try
to impact as many parents as i possibly
could around the world
um because if i couldn't make a huge
difference in that particular setting
you know we're doing our best
the information i held could make a huge
difference for other kiddos
um and parents who might not have access
to therapy so that was originally my why
and now
as i've really grown as a woman
a friend a wife a mother specifically
an intentional and conscious parenting
has been on my heart
my why is about really changing
how we show up as leaders for our kids
and i really think that you know we keep
going back to the inner work but
if we have this awareness and we can
develop the emotional intelligence
within ourselves
um this is going to have a huge impact
on our children and future generations
so it's it's still about children but
i've realized over the years
i can give all the information to
parents about child development but it
really starts with us
so now it's going back and saying like
we're step one
we need to learn to lead ourselves
before we lead our kiddos and so how can
i guide you through that like how can we
come together as a community and and
impact the world
that's a pretty amazing why that's
amazing
um ben what about you what was your why
to give people an example maybe they're
trying to get clarity
what would help them what was your why
yeah well beautiful shared nicole thank
you
you definitely live it to lead it so i
appreciate you
my why comes from avoid and i believe a
lot of voids
could be turned into a purpose so to
make uh
usually it's a longer share but i lost
my father back in 2014
through a lifestyle to be disease
diabetes right and
back then i didn't i didn't understand
the disease and he it was a nine months
of him being bedridden from a stroke
from his diabetes and it was a very
difficult
time in my life and i've once my father
passed away i wanted to
understand what happened to him why are
so many people
diagnosed with diabetes losing their
life including my father
so over the years i started to study
even more
health and fitness and nutrition
and the science of health and i came
across information that would have saved
my dad's life
and i realized that uh i was given that
mountain
so i could show the world that this
mountain can be moved so i understand
that
it is my duty my responsibility my
obligation to share this message
message of health and nutrition and
including mindset with the world and if
i don't i'm selfish
it's it's a selfish thing to do and if i
if i don't
if i don't do that so i know that this
information is transformational i know
it can make a big difference in the
world and that's what gives me stamina
because it would have saved my dad's
life so i want to be able
to not let that situation happen to
anybody else
and that is why i do what i do
that's pretty amazing wow that's
powerful and i think that's something
that people need to hear is that
sometimes people are starting in a
desperation or a really hard spot
they're starting from they're starting
from pain
and i feel like sometimes pain can be
the foundation of something great
because it's something that leaves a
mark in it and it drives you it's like
this is
i'm starting out of pain or i'm starting
out of loss and
now i want to i want to help other
people i mean we see amazing foundations
even created
you know the first one that comes to
mind is like the michael joc michael j
fox foundation
for like parkinson's like came birth out
of like
i have parkinson's at a young age this
is a scary disease i want to help change
that
and i think that sometimes we can't we
don't want to discount pain you know
it's actually can be such a gift and a
motivator
um to really see us through for our next
you know months years to come
and i think that's really powerful ben
that's a really powerful why
i want to transition a little bit and
and talk a little bit about where your
channels are now
what are some of the things you guys are
excited about coming up what are some
excited some things that are like
either you're like kind of just excited
about a new program you're launching or
something that you've seen some new
success in um i'd love to hear first
from you ben what are some new things
coming up that you're working on that
you're really excited about for your
channel
well i have a lofty goal to get uh to
have 1 million subscribers before the
year's up
so i'm excited about that you know what
setting these big goals it's really not
about
hitting the goal uh my my favorite
definition of success
comes from earl nightingale and he said
success is the progressive realization
of a worthy
ideal so an ideal is an idea that you
fall in love with i'm in love with
getting a million subscribers and
getting this information to a million
people so as long as i'm
every single day pursuing that goal i am
successful so whatever your goal is
whatever goal you fall in love with as
long as you're pursuing that goal
you are successful it is not until you
quit that you are unsuccessful so
stumbling blocks are just stepping
stones so for me that's a big goal
and if i get to 700 000 i'm happy
because i'm going to still every single
day pursue that goal so i'm excited
about that
i'm excited about the podcast we were
talking before this i'm excited about
vmix because i just
rolled it out and i'm going to do some
cool things with vmix and set
my live stream to a new level and then
also just learn the stuff that
you're teaching i know you guys get new
data all the time and i'm going to
absorb that data and apply it so i'm
excited about the new data that will
come my way from from you all
that's amazing that's an amazing goal
that's pretty cool
nicole you mentioned a little bit
earlier about some some book stuff going
on what are some new things on your
horizon what are you excited about with
your channel
well i have the safe and that's amazing
i need to step
my building up because i was like oh 100
000 by the end of the year yes okay
but i i love what ben said because it
goes back to just
like he wants a million subscribers by
the end of the year
and what matters is who's the person who
has
a million subscribers at the end of the
year and is he walking in
consistency with that person is he's
showing up as that person it's
a lot of energy right so i think that
that's beautiful
um yeah i am i'm very excited i'm very
excited about
these potential opportunities with books
and partnering i'm really excited about
coaching
entrepreneur mamas um because as i mean
i've listened to ben's story everyone
has an amazing story
and a gift to bring to this world and
and sometimes
it's our community our coaches our
mentors really help us break through to
that next level
and so each of us has a voice in which
the people resonate with right like
that's why it's like
so what that it's been done before only
you can say it the way you can say it
and some people will hear it only from
you
it will land differently for them and so
it's just this beautiful opportunity
that we have to help others
bring their vision and their goals to
life um i'm also
going to be launching a mastermind soon
so i'm super pumped on that
and yeah just just launched the nursing
program and a whole package for new moms
so just a lot of new um
courses and containers in which people
can work with me that i'm super fired up
about and then also just
content i'm i'm sort of gonna be
shifting some of the
content that's on my channel to reflect
this evolution and i'm really excited to
experiment with that and
um see where that goes that's amazing
you guys
are are so inspirational not even just
to
like the people watching i know for us
at think media there's there's people
there's a few names and you guys are
definitely in these names that we throw
around
look look what they're doing that's so
cool that inspires us oh my gosh that
was such a smart idea you guys did with
your video like we got to think that
through and
we literally look at people like you
guys and we're re-inspired by it as well
you know a lot of times
we're seen as the people teaching people
but it's funny and you guys might be
able to agree with us the people that
you're helping sometimes end up being
the ones that inspire
re-inspire you and give you fresh vision
and fresh ideas and things to really
um yeah to really take take hold of and
really take advantage of
and so as we're kind of summing up here
i kind of want to give one last i know
we kind of walked through a little bit
if you were early on we were starting
but if you were to give like just one
bit of motivation maybe maybe a couple
sentences or a few sentences of
motivation for people coming out of the
seven day challenge because
an event like this can be really
exciting and you get really really
charged up really excited and full of
like steam full of vision
what would be your tips or your tip for
them as coming out of the back side of
this challenge how they can continue to
see longevity
over the long haul and we'll start with
ben yes
uh i would say to throw your hat over
the fence and you got to go get it so
what does that mean make a commitment
make a commitment to what you want to do
maybe you're going to come out of the
seven day challenge and you're
inspired to release one video
with the framework every single week for
the next 12 months make a big commitment
to yourself throw that hat over the
fence
have somebody hold you accountable and
just keep pushing
forward keep pushing forward you know
you're going to have opportunities to
get
coaching on this you're going to have
opportunities to have that shortcut to
success
and i recommend taking advantage of it
you know it's one of the best
investments you can make
youtube is where it's at so throw your
hat over the fence make that strong
commitment have somebody hold you
accountable
and just keep chipping away at that goal
that's amazing
throw the hat over the fence i love that
analogy because i'm like yeah when you
throw a hat over the fence there's no
turning back if you have to go get the
hat
that's amazing nicole what would be your
what would be your advice to somebody
coming out of the back
back into this challenge i would say
um have have faith in your vision
and your why if it came to you there's a
reason
and while the journey might not always
be easy
there's a reason why you were given that
vision and
being able to grow and show up time and
time again
will bear fruit and even if
the views or the subscribers aren't
where you want them to be i always
always say to people you never know who
is watching your video
it doesn't matter that maybe a video
only has 100 views or 50 views
one person viewing that video could
change the trajectory of your life
could be the person who opens so many
doors
unexpectedly for you so just trusting
your vision
trust in what has been given to you and
your capability to see it through
well i hope you enjoyed that interview
that tony did with nicole and ben
and i'll make sure to link up all of
their information in the show notes for
you
but this actual interview came from our
recent
seven day youtube influence challenge we
have another one coming up
right around the corner and i want to
make sure you get registered for it
so you can go to tubeinfluence.com right
now to get all of the details on this
free challenge where you can learn how
to start or grow
your youtube channel right now you know
the economy is changing
things are changing business owners need
to learn how to pivot online
and we'll be teaching you how to
dominate on youtube with this
seven day free youtube influence
challenge so make sure you get
registered at tubeinfluence.com
and that leads us into the review of the
day
you can rate and review this podcast
over on
itunes and it really helps us to learn
what you're loving about the podcast
what we can change about the podcast but
also
it helps itunes show this to more people
so here is your review of the day it
comes from alex g
and alex says you guys blow my mind
every time
i consume any of your content this is by
far the best podcast i've ever
subscribed to i really love every one of
you and thank you so much for your
mission
well alex thank you so much for
recognizing that this is a team effort
just like you saw in this episode i'm
here sean's here tony's here
the think team is here and we are for
you so thank you so much for leaving
that review
over on itunes and make sure to
subscribe if you're
listening over on youtube and we'll
catch you in the next episode
you